but for now our eyes on the president
who has enjoyed rising approval ratings
and is intervening more and more
assertively to assist Republican
political candidates before this year's
midterm elections midterms typically go
badly for the incumbent party but can
trump special brand help turn the tide
that's the question we're joined tonight
by Fox senior political analyst Brit
Hume wait do these help the candidate
would you say you mean the candidate
that's up for election whose connection
for whom the president is stumped right
yes I think well I think in this case
possibly so the state of Tennessee is a
state that the president carried yes
easily there's a reasonably popular
candidate on the other side Phil
Bredesen the who's who's was governor
and there's been well regarded in the
state and he's ahead and what few polls
there are so but Marshall black born at
Bob Blackburn has a real chance to take
the seats for the Republicans and she
will need the support of the people who
voted for Trump she'll need other
support as well but she'll certainly
need that and his being there helps with
that and the other thing about it of
course is he loves this doubt about that
he just loves it I mean he gets I think
he you know in Washington he feels
cooped up and he feels criticized and
kind of like a man on an island then he
gets out to these rallies wouldn't he
taxis huge houses and they're all fully
advanced by his team and people come
into your wildly for him and he makes
him feel good and the Bill Clinton was
the same way he got energy from it he he
would people people who covered him on
his campaigns which I covered him as
president but not on a campaign would
say that at the end of the day everyone
would be exhausted and he seemed to be
tuned to be someone last rally people be
cheering like men suddenly he was in
full cry and roaring with energy and
couldn't get enough of it Trump seemed
much the same way so the debate over
whose party is the Republican Party's
kind of over I mean it's Trump's party
now for well it's it is but consider I
mean I think it's also fair to say
Tucker that for all the talk about how
the the party has been completely taken
over by Trump and that and it will not
in law it'll be his party in perpetuity
I think the Republican Party and its
ideologies have had more influence on
him and he's had on them hey why do you
say that well because you look at the
issues right taxes right he talked about
that but that wasn't that's that's a
central Republican tenant yes stronger
defense
so likewise the central plumbing intent
robust approach to foreign policy and
defense which is which the military is
part in that deregulation that's a big
that's been a Republican you know red
letter issue forever the only issues on
which he is departed from Republican
orthodoxy really our immigration and
trade and it's not at all clear when all
is said and done whether what comes out
of all this the policies that emerge
will be all that objectionable to the
Republican mainstream if there were a
third party challenge what would the
third party challenge a run on exactly
well I the only issue that I think that
well a third party challenge to trump
when the Republican or a third party
candidate within the Republican
primaries challenging right president it
would have to be on the issue of
personal character all right people
would say that we need there was no that
which is in a sense the issue that got
George W Bush elected but not
necessarily within the Republican ranks
it was a member and restore honor to the
White House remember that yes and of
course in the aftermath of the Clinton
scandals that carried weight in it and
it was damaging to Al Gore who had to
fight had to make the decision between
how closely the link himself to Clinton
and the and the robust economy and you
know it was argued forever that he
didn't do that enough or he did it you
know he did it too much but but that was
a burden on him for sure and Bush
character was capitalized on it whether
that will work in a Republican primary
at this stage I don't I don't think so
cuz I think Trump is kind of taking over
most of the Republican agenda so on the
issues you don't see any kind of
challenge for the nomination
well people I mean I don't I just don't
think anybody can challenge him sort of
from the left on immigration right well
particularly on trade although one of
the problems with Trump's trade agenda
is that it could go wrong and we could
end up you know with trade barriers up
that now that we've sort of backed into
or you know
so blustered our way into and the
economy could get hurt by that and you
know you could have somebody running
against him on the economy but the
economy would have to go pretty far
south from where it is now for that to
happen
how buiid do you think Trump is and
Republicans are by the potential North
Korean deal well I think Trump was
pretty excited about it about the
potential of it but I will say this I
mean I my concern has been in his now
that he go he gets into a into a summit
and gets and gets so excited about the
possibility of what he can call a deal
that would denuclearize it and and and
the Korean War and all the rest of it
that he makes a bad deal that he gets
you Kurd which is what's you know it's
happened before repeatedly yeah so far
though it seems to me that despite his
excited talk and his buying in at least
a little bit to the Nobel Prize talk and
his willingness to say okay this is off
suggests to me that you know he's got
his eyes wide open and the people around
him do too and that if this if he gets
over there and or they try to organize
this thing and it's coming to not that
he's willing to walk away and but if he
didn't do that and he got into a bad
deal that might leave a vulnerability so
the indicators for right now and these
things change but are pointing in the
right direction for Republicans for the
for the White House they certainly look
a lot better than I did six months it
much better so what would happen if
Democrats failed to retake the House of
Representatives well what would the
reckoning be like do you think within
the Democratic Party well it would be
pretty serious I mean I you know and I I
think that the the the message that
would probably come out of that would be
that being you know just overwhelmingly
antitrump is not enough that while that
awakens the sentiments in the base and
is responsible for love the energy in
the Democratic Party these days that
that in itself is not enough it's too
negative it doesn't you know paint a
picture of how much better things could
be it doesn't you know really arouse
people who were you know most most
people are not passionate one way or the
other most people are you know they're
willing to vote in the midterm on when
we hear from somebody who who says look
like I can make things better for you
here's how and
if you haven't got that in a in a
weighted and if you if you run into
Democrats some Democrats seem prepared
to do it
look vote for me I'll raise your taxes
that's probably not gonna work either do
you see any stirrings within the
Democratic Party which is aligned
realigning just as I think the
Republican Party is though it gets very
little coverage but any stirrings of a
positive agenda here's you know we're
against Trump of course we are but
here's what were for do you see anything
well on those lines I don't but I'm not
sure how we'd know I mean the truth is
when you get down to it the truth is
when you get down to it Tucker that
there not a lot of really new ideas
these are you know you're usually for
you know reining in government
controlling spending all the Republicans
have kind of given up on that and at
least in recent times lower taxes
sterner defense tougher foreign policy
all of that right yeah soft regulation
Democrats are for the opposite things
and there always will be I mean that's
what they're about you know so so you're
gonna run our platform that says look
you know Trump is destroying the
environment he's letting in the
corporate moguls run amok and and the
big banks are cashing in his number
before we got to put a stop to this
that will attract some support but
that's preached that seems pretty tired
right now certainly does it certainly
does Brit Hume thank you very much for
that preciate it